Kein Problem.
Ich höre.
Guten Abend.
Ich heiße Hamidi.
Ich bin als Assistentarzt auf dieser Station Tethisch.
Und wurde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmengespräch durchführen.
Sind Sie einverstanden?
Ja, Herr Doktor, natürlich.
Aber zuerst ich stelle ein paar allgemeine Fragen.
Dann kommen wir zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden.
Ist das in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja, aber ich komme lange da,
ich habe starke Beschwerden, Herr Doktor.
Ganz schnell.
Bitte?
Ja, ganz schnell.
Nur zwei, drei Fragen.
Ah, okay, bitte schön.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Ulrike Heinrich.
Ulrike Heinrich.
Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Heinrich?
Ich bin 56 Jahre alt.
56 Jahre alt.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Wann bin ich genau geboren?
28. Juli, 1916.
Was war das?
66.
Ja, genau.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Bitte?
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ach so, meine Größe wollen Sie wissen.
Ich bin 1,65 Meter.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege circa,
also 78 Kilo.
Okay, was ist da vor Sie zu uns?
Oh Herr Doktor, das ist ganz schlimm.
Ich habe so Krämpfe im Oberbauch.
Seit zwei Tagen.
Ich kann kaum essen.
Wo genau, im Oberbauch?
Also hier in der Mitte, ich glaube, ich vermute mal,
dass das der Magen ist.
Mitte.
Und da könnt ihr mir bitte beschreiben,
wie viele Krämpfe Sie haben,
die Schmerzen?
Ja, das ist so krampfartig.
Das ist so richtig krampfartig.
Und manchmal mehr, manchmal weniger.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich muss oft das mal aufstoßen.
Und in letzter Zeit habe ich auch Übelkeit.
Und gestern Abend habe ich auch einmal erbrochen.
Wie viele Mal erbrochen?
Gestern einmal.
Okay, wir sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10.
Wobei 1 sehr leichte Schmerzen
und 10 sehr stärke Schmerzen entspricht.
Das ist sehr unterschiedlich.
Im Moment würde ich sagen, so 4 bis 5.
Oder vielleicht sogar mehr.
Aber manchmal habe ich das Gefühl,
auch noch viel stärker.
Ja.
Sind die Schmerzen nach Essen?
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass es nach dem Essen
sogar schlimmer wird.
Sie haben gesagt, die Schmerzintensität
4 bis 5.
Und manchmal mehr.
Ich verstehe, dass die Schmerzen
dauerhaft sind.
Seit 2 Tagen, ja, kann man schon sagen,
das stimmt.
Gestern sprechen die Schmerzen
wohin aus?
Mein ganzes Bauch tut natürlich weh.
Ich bin so aufgebläht.
Ich kann mich nicht richtig hinsetzen.
Ich habe keinen Appetit.
Ich möchte nichts essen.
Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl,
es ist sehr eng auf der Brust.
Ich kriege schlecht Luft.
Haben Sie etwas angenommen?
Schmerzmittel?
Ich mag keine Tabletten.
Deswegen habe ich lange Zeit nichts genommen.
Aber nach dem,
die Schmerzen schlimmer wurden, habe ich eine Tablette
Paracetamol genommen.
Das hat nichts geholfen.
Haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerden?
Früher? Nein, habe ich nicht gehabt.
Das ist erst einmal.
Immer wieder mal eine leichte Übelkeit.
Aber das ist jetzt ganz schlimm.
Haben Sie Brünen?
Seit gestern.
Ich merke, wie das in die Speiseröhre
oder bis zum Hals hochzieht.
Da habe ich auch.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Das ist nicht gut.
Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl,
ich bekomme schlecht Luft.
Aber im Moment eigentlich nicht.
Gibt es bestimmte Ausslüsse
für diese Schmerzen?
Das kann ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Ich habe letzte Woche
zum Essen eingeladen.
Da habe ich mich vielleicht ein bisschen
zu viel gegessen.
Es gab schönes Essen
und auch viel Alkohol.
Ich hatte schon längere Zeit nicht so viel gegessen.
Es waren auch einige Schaden.
Ich kann mir gut vorstellen,
dass das vielleicht der Ausser ist.
Ich habe nicht gehört.
Wann war das?
Vor einer Woche.
Und diese Beschwerden
seit zwei Tagen?
Ja, seit zwei Tagen sind sie stark.
Aber das hat vorher schon angefangen.
Ich sage,
in der Zusammenfassung
haben Sie seit ungefähr
eine Woche eingeladen.
Sie haben viele gegessen
und getrunken.
Wir waren eingeladen zum Essen.
Wir hatten eingeladen.
Sie waren eingeladen.
Wir waren eingeladen.
Sie haben viele Essen und Alkohol getrunken.
Sie fuhlen nicht gut.
Sie haben später Schmerzen.
Oberbauchschmerzen.
Manchmal strahlen sie in den ganzen Bauch aus.
Obelkeit.
Manche haben es nicht gut.
Sie haben gestern einmal
verbrochen.
Schmerzintensität.
Manchmal stärker.
Sie haben Paracetamol angenommen,
aber nicht geholfen.
Es hat nichts geholfen.
Diese Beschwerden sind erst mal.
Sie hatten keine ähnliche Beschwerden.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein.
Ich habe mir nicht aufgefallen.
Haben Sie bemerkt,
dass Ihre Gewicht verändert hat?
Ich meine in letzter Zeit.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Sind die Schmerzen langsam
oder plötzlich aufgetreten?
Langsam.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Wasserlassen
und Stuhlgang?
Nein, aber ich bin ziemlich gebläht.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich habe viel Luft.
Aber ich habe das Gefühl, ich habe viel Luft.
Ich habe heute Morgen einen sehr dunklen
und schwarzen Stuhlgang.
Das war einmal, ja?
Ja.
Wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Seit zwei Tagen ist es eigentlich ganz schlecht.
Ist Ihnen das schwindelig?
Nein, ich habe nur etwas übel.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich muss
erbrechen.
Aber ich habe nicht Schwindel.
Gut.
Herr Brauch,
Herr Heinrich,
ich frage Sie über
gesundes Gericht.
Haben Sie vor Erkrankungen
oder leiden Sie einen chronischen Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe hohe Blutdruck
und ich habe eine schilddrösen Unterfunktion.
Seit wann haben Sie einen Blutdruck?
Seit fünf, sechs Jahren, glaube ich.
Und der schönes Gericht?
Ja, unterfunktion.
Das habe ich schon seit fast 20 Jahren.
Seitdem habe ich einen Schilddrösen.
Ja, das ist ja schon seit 20 Jahren.
Seit über 20 Jahren?
Sonst?
Sonst ist alles ok.
Und wurden Sie schon einmal berührt?
Nein.
Als meine Kinder geboren wurden,
hatte ich einen Kaiserschnitt.
Aber sonst nicht.
Was haben Sie denn?
Ein Kaiserschnitt.
Wie war das?
Bei meinem zweiten Kind.
Wie viele Jahre?
Das sind jetzt 26 Jahre her.
Ist Ihre Impfstatus vollständig?
Meine Impfungen meinen Sie?
Ja, meine Impfungen.
Ja, da war ich erst vor kurzem.
Der meinte, die Impfungen sind komplett.
Gut.
Haben Sie gegen Corona geimpft?
Ich bin geimpft.
Ich habe drei Impfungen bisher.
Die letzte Impfung ist vor circa drei Monaten gemacht worden.
Gut.
Haben Sie erledigenergeblich etwas?
Ja, ich habe es vor kurzem.
Ich habe einen Hausstauballergie.
Und gegen Nickel habe ich eine Allergie.
Nickel.
Treiben Sie Sport?
Das würde ich gerne machen, aber leider nicht.
Nicht?
Nein.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben viele getrunken.
Letzte Woche.
Aber allgemein, wie viel trinken Sie?
Was?
Was meinen Sie, was ich trinke?
Alkohol.
Ja, ich trinke Alkohol.
Aber nicht so oft habe ich einen Wein.
Ich trinke auch immer.
Beim Essen haben wir etwas mehr Wein getrunken.
Aber ansonsten trinke ich nicht so viel.
Wir können ein bisschen besser bestimmte sagen.
Wie viel trinken Sie täglich?
Ich trinke täglich, trinke ich nicht.
Vielleicht so zweimal die Woche.
Zweimal die Woche.
Und Wein, ja?
Nein, ich trinke Wein.
Zweiglasse, ja?
Ein Glas Wein.
Okay.
Herr Englisch, nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Nennen Sie Drogen?
Drogen?
Was meinen Sie mit Drogen?
Hast ich Kokain, Heroin,
Ach so, solche Sachen?
Nein, nein, das nehme ich nicht.
Ich habe mal früher in meiner Studentenzeit
ein bisschen hastig probiert, aber seitdem nicht mehr.
Einmal, ja?
Ja, mehrfach probiert, aber in der Jugendlichen Zeit
macht jeder.
Okay, leitern Sie,
wenn Sie das nicht tun,
dann haben Sie die Kinder, die nicht tun.
Leitern Sie Ihre Eltern an freundlicher Krankung?
Ja, mein Vater hat
Typ 2 Diabetes.
Er hat auch noch so durch Blutungsstörungen
an seinen Füßen.
Und er hat Mobus Parkinson.
Bluthochdruck und Parkinson?
Ja.
Er hat leider letztes Jahr
eine Diagnose bekommen.
Er hat ein Eierstockkrebs.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe noch einen Bruder.
Ist er gesund?
Dem geht es gut.
Er ist circa 4 Jahre rühnker als ich.
Er ist sportlich, ist gesund,
er achtet auf seine Gesundheit.
Dem geht es gut.
Herr Heinrich, was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin Lehrerin.
Und wer sind Sie für Ihre Eltern?
Ja, seit über 35 Jahren.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Das haben Sie mich schon gefragt.
Ich habe eine kleine Familie,
eine Frau und ein Sohn.
Ich habe Geschwister gefragt.
Ich habe ein Bruder und zwei Kinder gesagt.
Und leben Sie zusammen?
Mit wem?
Mit der Familie.
Die Kinder sind aus dem Haus.
Ich wohne mit meinem Mann zusammen.
Haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit?
Ja, ich bin ein Lehrer.
Ich bin sehr anstrengend.
Ich habe immer Stress, aber es macht mir Spaß.
Ich liebe meine Arbeit.
Frau, ich habe eine Frau.
Ich habe eine Frau.
Frau Heinrich,
ich habe die wichtigen Fragen gestellt.
Mussten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Vielen Dank,
das war jetzt ein sehr ausführliches Gespräch.
Ist es etwas Schlimmes, das meinen Sie?
Also ich möchte Sie mir helfen,
die Schmerzen irgendwie wegzubekommen?
Ja, natürlich.
bleiben, weil sie haben dunkle Stuhlgang und das ist ein bisschen, wir müssen das aufklären,
die Ursache. Was muss ich da machen? Muss ich wirklich hier bleiben? Ich will aber eigentlich
nicht im Krankenhaus bleiben. Ja, Sie sind im Krankenhaus. Ja, aber ich will hier nicht bleiben,
ich möchte nur, dass meine Schmerzen mehr gehen. Ja, ja, ich habe gesagt, Sie haben dunkle Stuhlgang
und das ist ein bisschen stüriose und wir müssen die Ursache wissen. Ja, ist es schlimm,
was bedeutet das, so ein schwarzes Stuhlgang? Jetzt kann ich nicht bestimmte Diagnose stellen,
ich habe aber verdachte Diagnose, Sie haben Blutung von Ihrer Magin oder Ocephagus oder
Magin oder Ocephagus. Und wir müssen mehr untersuchen. Was macht man dafür in Untersuchung,
kriege ich einen Ultraschall oder? Ja, wir korrigieren untersuchen, auch Blutabnahme,
Bauch Ultraschall und gegebenenfalls Endoscopy, das bedeutet Spiegelung,
Merkenspiegelung. Ach so, muss das jetzt sofort sein oder? Kann ich das nicht zu Hause machen,
das ist ein Hausarzt? Ja, wir machen das morgen, weil Sie müssen einige Stunden ohne Essen. Ja,
ich habe seit 6 Stunden nichts gegessen. Ja, und auf jeden Fall haben Sie nicht sehr
stärke Symptome, so Spiegelung können wir morgen machen. Ja, kann ich nicht morgen kommen,
ich gehe heute nach Hause und komme morgen wieder. Nein, nein, weil vielleicht jeden Zeit Sie konnten
Hilfe brauchen. Was meinen Sie mit Hilfe? Ist das etwas Schlimmes, was passiert denn da? Ja, zum Beispiel
sehr stärke Schmerzen oder Obelkeit, Erbrechen, Sie haben einmal Erbrechen und das können noch
wieder kommen. Ja, gut, das habe ich jetzt schon seit 2 Tagen, das ist ja, das geht es
einigermaßen. Also wie sind Sie ja, Doktor, ich möchte eigentlich nicht im Krankenhaus bleiben.
Na ja, Sie können unterstrich- lich. Also ich soll unterschreiben. Unterschreiben,
Sie möchten keine Weitmuster bleiben, aber ich empfehle Ihnen, bei uns zu bleiben.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie nicht. Ist es etwas Lebensgefährliches oder? Nicht Lebensgefährlich,
aber wir mussten vor Zukunft denken, nicht nur vor diesem Moment. Ja,
was kann denn passieren? Ja, das können auch noch wieder Blutung machen, passieren.
Das heißt es kann eine Blutung kommen? Ja, Blut kommen, Stärke, Schmerzen oder ich
möchte nicht vieler Erklärer erklären, weil ich möchte keine Sorgen machen vor Sie.
Nein, aber ich möchte schon, dass Sie mir offen und ehrlich erklären, was Ihre Vermutung ist.
Ich möchte ja wissen, was ich habe. Okay, dann sage ich, Sie können Blutung noch einmal
kommen und ich habe auch gesagt, wieder Stärke, Schmerzen und eventuell Perforation
ist weichnächst. Perforation ist eine schwierige Komplikation für Ihre Gesundheit.
Was bedeutet Perforation? Das habe ich nicht verstanden. Perforation,
wie kann ich sagen, das ist auch Blut. Sie sind Perforation. Ist es sowas, dass da eigentlich
ein Durchbruch entsteht oder ein Loch entsteht oder was? Loch, Loch, Loch, ja, Loch in Wadi,
in der Maginweiß. Ach so, und das ist gefährlich, das
hört sich schon gefährlich. Ja, sehr gefährlich. Wenn Sie sagen, dass es so
schlimm und gefährlich ist, dann bleibe ich natürlich da, aber sehr ungern. Ja, das ist
sehr gefährlich und das erleben Sie bedrohlich. Okay, wenn es so ist, dann bleibe ich natürlich da,
Herr Doktor. Okay, danke schön und wir jetzt die korbischen Prüfungen durchführen, ganz schnell und danach
wir machen die anderen korbischen Prüfungen. Okay, vielen Dank. Haben Kollegen andere Fragen,
Medikamenten nicht gegeben? Medikamenten haben Sie? Ja, Medikamenten. Welche Medikamenten
nehmen Sie bitte? Okay, welche Erkrankungen habe ich noch mal? Ja, Sie haben ...
Und Schilddrüse, genau. Ich nehme Amnodipin, fünf Milligramm.
Einmal am Morgen, genau. Und gegen die Schilddrüse oder für die Schilddrüse nehme ich Euterox 75.
Euterox. Euterox. Ja. Wie viele Milligramm? 75. Mikrogramm, ja. Ich weiß nicht, was es ist,
ich glaube Milligramm sind es, aber Euterox 75 steht drauf. Ja, okay. Einmal. Ja, das nehme ich immer vor dem Frühstück.
Wie sieht diese Erbrochene aus? Das kann ich jetzt nicht sagen, das war jetzt gestern Abend, das war
vom Essen ein bisschen was und so ein bisschen hat übel gerauchen. Ich hatte das Gefühl,
da sind auch ein paar kleine blutige Fäden drin, ja das stimmt. Wenn ihr Bauchschmerzen bekommen
und noch etwas zur selben Zeit außer Atemnot, ein bisschen Atemnot und ein bisschen in der Brust,
noch andere zum Beispiel Schweißigkeit. Also Kaltschweißigkeit meine ich.
Kaltschweißigkeit, Kalptin, Herzrasen, Herzstolpern. Ja, ab und zu mal habe ich Herzrasen, das stimmt, wenn Sie das so sagen,
aber am sonstigen halb ich ja vorhin alles schon gesagt.
Sind Sie desgegen schon bei einem andere Naskewesen? Nein, nein, ich bin jetzt gleich zu Ihnen gekommen,
weil die Schmerzen schlimmer geworden sind. Noch andere Fragen, unsere Kollegen?
Keine. Alsatzgejübre, können wir anfangen?
Nur eine Minute bitte, ich organisiere die.
Hat unsere Oberarzt keine Zeit?
Ja ja, der Oberarzt muss weg.
Okay, dann ich versuche.
Guten Abend Herr Oberarzt.
Ah, unser neue Kollege, wundern Dr. Mohammed, Hallo.
Hallo, danke schön. Ich wurde die neuen Patienten vorstellen, haben Sie kurz Zeit vor mich?
Aber natürlich, bitte schön, was haben Sie denn für einen Fall?
Ihre Name ist Ulige Heinrich, sie ist 56 Jahre alt und zwar geboren am 28. Juli 1966.
Sie ist 1,65 m groß und wiegt 78 kg.
Die Patientin hat sich bei uns, bei uns wegen seit einigen Tagen, ungefähr eine Woche,
auf getretenen, bewirbenden Schmerzen in Oberbauch, in den Mitte Oberbauch,
in Erwigerung vorgestellt. Sie berüchtete, dass die Schmerzintensität
4, 5 und manchmal stärker entspricht, auf der Schmerzskale entspricht.
Die Patientin berüchtete auch Ober-, Oberwildkeit und nausea und einmal Mesis gestern
mit Blut, Blutig- und Essen-Naterial.
Essen-Resten, okay.
Die klagte, dass die Schmerzen krampfartig sind und langsam aufgetreten.
Die Frage nach Ausstrahlung wurde verneint.
Eigentlich mit Ausstrahlung nach ganz Abdomen, total Abdomen, aber die Schmerze konzentriert in
Evigastrio. Dagegen hätte sie Paracetamol angenommen, aber ohne Hilfe.
Diese Beschwerden habe sie vorherige nicht gehabt. Sie klagte auch über leichter bis neu.
Die Frage nach Auslöser gab eine sehr viele verschiedene Essen und sehr viele Alkohol
trinken. Die vegetative Mese war unauffällig bis auf Inhabitanz seit 2 Tagen.
Was erlassen war unauffällig. Die Patientin gab an, dass die Stuhlgang sei dunkel.
Das heißt, sie hat Milena einmal gestern. Auch andere Beschwerden klagten die Patientin
über Sudbrunnen.
Nach der Schweiß.
An Vorerkrankungen sind bekannt eine arterielle Hypertunie seit 5-6 Jahren.
Dagegen nimmt sie 5 Milligramm morgens.
Bei der Patientin wurde die Ziesare für 26 Jahre geblieben.
Der Status ist vollständig. Sie ist 3 Mal gegen Corona COVID-19 geimpft.
Allergien berüstete die Patientin.
Sie treibt keine Sport.
Sie fragte nach Tabakkonsum wurde vernein.
Alkohol trinkt das Verkauf der Ziesare.
Sie trinkt 2 Mal pro Woche.
Ein, 2 Glas Wein.
Die Patientin ergeben eine Diabetes-Militus, 2 und 3 Hypertunie, wie Parking bei der Vater.
Die Mutter leidet ein Eierstück Krebs.
Sie ist ein Bruder, der gesund ist.
Die Patientin ist Lehrerin von Beruf.
Sie hat 2 gesunde Kinder.
Sie hat reduzierte Allgemeinzustand.
Sie hat Stress bei der Arbeit.
Die Patientin hat reduzierte Allgemeinzustand.
Sie ist in einem guten Ernährungskontakt.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Die Verdachtdiagnose ist oberblutung.
Das ist eine obergesto-intestinale Blutung.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Die Verdachtdiagnose ist obergehebenblutung.
Dann Blutabnahme und operative Untersuchungen.
Erste Schritt,
Wir schließen die nirgendrenne Pathologie und die penkretische Veränderungen.
Was ist Ihre Differenzialdiagnose?
Wie ich gesagt habe, verschiedene Ursache für die Blutung.
Auch kommen penkretitis.
Was heißt herpothozerorose?
Ah, zeroose.
Und auch Varizelusophagus varizen.
Auch die Vertikulitis.
Ja, die Differenzialdiagnose ist mehr im Unterbauch.
Die Chronischen Ärzte,